the star of watch dogs is aiden pearce a
vigilante who uses his smartphone to
manipulate surveillance cameras traffic
lights and even the electricity supply
in a fictional version of chicago he can
even access the personal records of his
fellow citizens it took the watchdogs
developers five years and fifty million
euros to perfect the game nowadays game
designers have to pull out all the stops
to keep players excited giddap has won
every person walking around in Chicago
has their own identity and when Aiden
Pearce interacts with them something
happens in the game he leaves an
impression behind that's part of the
innovation you can't invent something
like that in a year yeah a feeling or
does he Oh staying video games are now
rivaling Hollywood blockbusters in cost
the game Star Wars The Old Republic cost
150 million euros it's the third most
expensive computer game ever made the
production and marketing of grand theft
auto 5 costs 200 million euros just
hours after it's released the game's
Scottish manufacturers had recoup their
costs
it hasn't been released yet but destiny
is estimated to have cost a record 360
million euros computer games typically
cost nine figure sums to produce these
days they have to sell a lot of copies
to break even producing a computer game
is not like working on the set of a
feature film where you walk around with
a camera everything you see is created
on a computer so personnel costs are
high that's the biggest cost with Santo
one of Germany's biggest training
centers for computer game programmers is
located in trio at the moment the
students are working on one of the
newest gamepad systems the sector is
growing computer games now generate more
income than feature films at the same
time the image of computer games has
changed almost one in two Germans
regularly play computer games now it is
there even regarded as cultural assets
which question this Bob can mean it's
not a medium that's regarded as new by
young people as a perhaps was in my
generation back then the defining medium
was television nowadays the computer
game is increasingly becoming the
defining medium for young adults yeah
unboxing in today's game designers have
to keep dreaming a bigger and better
tricks for their increasingly demanding
customers to make on-screen movement
look as realistic as possible the
producers use expensive and
time-consuming motion capture technology
actors Don suits kitted out with sensors
and multiple cameras are used the
technology was deployed to particularly
good effect in the game beyond two souls
which hit the market last autumn
hollywood actors ellen page in willem
dafoe were employed by the parisian game
studio quantic dream to create the
characters movements in beyond 2 souls
the distinctions between film and game
become blurred Jesus whether the
charisma of certain actors can be
transferred to virtual characters is
impossible to ascertain at this point in
time that something is my loss it's been
tried once or twice and it was quite
well received they know it's a long shot
we like animation set but acting on a
real set is a little different from
acting on a virtual one might say but
it's wouldn't off presenters but games
can be produced without motion capture
or Hollywood actors the independent
Swedish game papers please for example
in the role of a border guard the player
decides whether to allow immigrants to
enter the country despite its relatively
old fashioned graphics the game was
critically acclaimed and recently won
the Lara prize for best international
computer game kidneys Norma don't woman
it's not just about investing more money
being bigger and more realistic or
having better sound effects it's about
creating intelligent entertainment and
depending games can achieve that to
independent games on the game watch dogs
employees impressive cutting-edge
graphics it's a high-gloss production
that could almost be a film so it should
come as no surprise that there are plans
afoot to turn the game into a movie
you